this exhibition is goddess heroine beast
Anna hi huntington's New York sculpture
1902 to 1936 it features the early work
of Anna hi at Huntington who is a
beloved sculptor whose work is all
around us in New York City who's been
sadly a bit forgotten well first I saw
her sculptures in the American Court at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art and then
I noticed that there was a Joan of Arc
monument at Riverside in 93rd and then
somehow every institution I I found
there was yet another anna von hi at
Huntington sculpture and I thought this
is a neighborhood kind of topic Ian
wanted to work with her students with a
class ranging from undergraduate to
graduate in our history and other fields
to work on every single aspect of the
exhibition from research to installation
to practical matters they help with the
design they did everything well there
were very few really successful public
women artists at the time but what anna
hyatt as she was then named understood
was that new york city institutions were
so ambitious that they were willing to
take some risks on some very unlikely
artists enough on high at Huntington
specialized in animal sculptures and
that was not such an extraordinary thing
to do but then lo and behold in 1910 she
made a major animal sculpture that had a
Joan of Arc attached to it and that
suddenly launched her into the
unprecedented domain of representing
great heroic women in outdoor public
monuments hyatt Huntington worked with
the Joan of Arc iconography for many
years and developed different versions
of the image of Joan of Arc but the
Commission here in New York City on
Riverside Drive is really significant
because it's the first public monument
by a woman and of an actual historical
woman well I think Anna
hi at Huntington is a role model for all
of our students because she dreamed big
and she achieved even bigger and then I
think it's important for Barnard and
Columbia to really be in their
neighborhoods and pay attention to
what's all around us